some movie characters are iconic in
their own right
and some are made iconic by the actors
who play them
have you ever watched a movie and
noticed a slight difference
maybe it was something in their voice or
something in their face but there was
definitely something off
actors are recast all the time in
hollywood and today
we're going to show you which actors
originally played what role
who replaced them and why join me in
this circle
there are mixed feelings towards this
replacement in the first installment of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
grindelwald was portrayed by johnny depp
however
mads mikkelsen will be taking over the
role as depp was fired for allegations
of domestic abuse towards his ex-wife
amber heard while depp is not spoken out
about how he feels about losing the role
mikkelsen had this to say in an
interview with entertainment weekly
there has to be a bridge between what
johnny did and what i'm going to do
and at the same time i also have to make
it my own for freedom
and for love in harry potter the series
we all know and love
the character lavender brown was first
portrayed by two black actresses
kathleen cawley and jennifer smith
however when the role grew bigger and
more important to the storyline
the part was given to jessie cave a
white actress
many fans have accused the filmmakers of
white washing in this instance
the reason for this change was that as
the part grew the filmmakers needed an
experienced actress to take on the role
and they found that in jessie cave
batman is an iconic character and has
been featured in countless movies since
1966.
the character has seen many actors and
in recent years the part has changed
from christian bale to ben
affleck to as of now robert pattinson
and it seems that
bale has some advice to give to
pattinson in terms of playing the role
don't listen to those guys do his own
thing he's a fascinating actor he's a
great choice
in twilight we were terrified of the
character victoria
she was first played by rochelle lefeve
in the original twilight film and the
second movie new moon but
the role went to bryce dallas howard for
eclipse
apparently the change was due to a
scheduling conflict
according to an interview with howard
the two met at a restaurant to discuss
the change
the way the business is there's this
notion that it's competitive and that's
actually
not the case at all claire foy stole our
hearts as queen elizabeth ii
in the first two seasons of netflix the
crown while you might expect her to play
the character for the duration of the
series
foy knew from the get-go that she would
only be queen elizabeth ii for two
seasons
we always knew it was only gonna be two
series so i'm completely from
from the beginning it's always been what
i've known as the story progressed and
the queen aged
the creators needed a new actress they
decided that olivia coleman would be
perfect for the role in batman begins
the character rachel dawes batman's
friend and love interest
was portrayed by katie holmes however
she did not return for the sequel the
dark knight
because of scheduling conflicts the role
then went to maggie gyllenhaal who was
honored and delighted to take on the
character
i think it's important to make movies
that people see you know try and
you know really affect a lot of people
with what we do and so i'm really
pleased
in the first two harry potter movies the
iconic albus dumbledore was played by
richard harris
he took on the iconic role because of
his granddaughter and then your
granddaughter said take it immediately
she said if you don't do it i won't
speak to you so i had to do it
unfortunately he passed away at 72 after
the second movie
and the role then went to michael gambin
like batman
spider-man is a beloved superhero that
has seen many actors over the years
the character does not belong to one
actor even though the character has
brought many actors to start him
doing the spider-man stuff i felt guided
into it i knew it was the right thing
for me to do
he's been portrayed by andrew garfield
and most recently
tom holland he seems to be aging down
along with spider-man is his memorable
aunt may
she too went through an actor change for
andrew garfield's era
sally field played her and now she's
played by marissa tomei for the tom
holland era
like spider-man the character seems to
be aging down the change was noted by
fans everywhere
as aunt may is often depicted as an
elderly woman given the comics
check out this interview where they talk
about it aging is
natural and beautiful we shouldn't be
like ah i feel so strange about it
hulk was originally played by edward
norton in the incredible hulk
but for the rest of marvel's movies the
hulk was played by mark ruffalo
the creative minds that brought the mcu
to life decided to go in a different
direction for the character
which is why the actor was recast
despite this
norton bears no ill will toward ruffalo
and
robert downey my dear friend introduces
me as
and now reprising the role of the hulk
rebecca romain first played mystique
when the character was introduced in
x-men
but she was soon replaced by jennifer
lawrence for future movies involving the
character
the actress was replaced because the
filmmakers needed to age mystique down
as the movies they were making took
place before x-men
i think it's fascinating to see it at
the very beginning
people chose sides and but you get to
see why
famous actress shailene woodley was the
first actress to play the oc's caitlyn
cooper
the younger sister of marissa cooper she
was replaced with an older actress wiela
holland
according to woodley the change was made
because woodley hadn't gone through
puberty yet and they needed a girl who
had a body
it had been three days before my
birthday when i found out so it's a
great early birthday present
in friends we all know carol ross's
first ex-wife
we first knew her with actress anita
barone but she was later recast with
jane sabette
although varone only played carol for
one episode fans certainly noticed a
change
however sibet who played carol for the
rest of the series
did an amazing job with the role barron
left the role to pursue more full-time
ones
as carol was not a regular on friends so
here's how sebette got the part
and i picked up the phone and it was my
agent saying hey
remember that show friends in netflix
popular show big mouth
missy was initially voiced by jenny
slate but for the new season
slate is being replaced with american
comedian iowa debris
this change is important because missy
who was a mixed race character
will be voiced by a black woman
representation matters
this is so cool and so funny and so
different
this is like a dream job in the first
season of family guy the character meg
is played by lacey chabert in season two
she was replaced by mila kunis
the reason she left is because of
chabert's schooling and her work on
party of five
it all worked out for the best though
because kunis is perfect for the role of
meg griffin
there was an addition i went on it
and then they said you have to come back
but you have to speak slower
rachel weiss portrayed evelyn carnahan
in the mummy and its sequel
but she was recast for the third film
with maria bello
apparently vice had issues with the
script which led to bello getting the
part
it was a dream come true for the actress
he wanted me to do the mummy and it just
blew my mind
it was my biggest dream since i was a
kid we loved dash from the incredibles
and we loved spencer fox's portrayal of
the character
however the sequel features huck
milner's voice for the character
why well nearly 15 years separated the
incredibles and its sequel
but the second one takes place right
after the first one's conclusion
spencer fox had grown too old to voice
the character here's how milner landed
the part
voice acting is really cool because you
can you don't it doesn't matter what you
look like you can just
go into a booth and just say oh yeah i'm
this character now
halloweentown is a classic disney
channel original
especially during spooky season the
movie did so well that three sequels
were ordered with kimberly j
brown as the star until the fourth one
when she was replaced by sarah paxton
there have been
several rumors about why this
replacement occurred much to fans dismay
but this is what brown had to say on the
matter disney decided to
go in a different direction and recast
the role mike myers is famous for his
work as shrek
but he wasn't the original voice for the
character in fact
the character was initially voiced by
chris farley an american comedian
nearly all the dialogue had been
recorded when farley sadly passed away
meyers stepped in and let shrek his
iconic voice
check out how different these two
interpretations are they judge me before
they even know me they judge me before
they even know me
in the office pam's mom helene was
played by shannon cochrane when we first
see her
while the creators wanted to bring
cochrane back when we see helene again
in later seasons
she was unavailable consequently the
role went to linda pearl and she did a
great job
cake's really good oh i know i love when
they use buttercream frosting
it's nice when the same actor can play a
character in every iteration
but sometimes a change is necessary
whether it's because someone's too busy
or they weren't right for the role every
actor does their best to bring their
given character to life
as long as we get a good movie as an end
result we're happy
which character role change surprised
you the most let us know
down in the comments thanks for watching
[Music]
you